Breaking news.
This is live pictures.
Former President
Trump is about to land in New Jersey
and then he's going to go straight
to his club in Bedminster.
We anticipate he's
but we know he's going to meet
with donors and anticipate
he'll give a speech about
30 minutes long.
He, of course,
pleaded not guilty to 37
counts of handling classified documents
in Florida today.
And I just want to show you a new image
because we've been showing you
one courtroom
image,
the court drawing where he was standing
alongside his.
His lawyers
and whatnot in the background.
Here is a plane landing in Newark.
But we do now have this one, which is
still doesn't really look like him,
I'll be honest. Maybe 30 years ago. But
crossing his arms
Ty Cobb is with me, of course, former
Trump White House lawyer. So, Ty.
Here's the thing.
He our reporters who are in the room
describe him.
His plane is landing here.
Describe him as slumped over, scowling,
looking
dejected at moments,
for lack of a better word, a
and he was silent, right?
Obviously, he didn't address the sport
at all.
His lawyer did all the talking for him.
You've represented him in the past.
Do you read anything into this
You know, some
I you know,
I didn't actually represent him
personally.
I represented the White House,
but I was advising him.
And that's Trump, you know,
when he basically wishes
he was somewhere else.
You know, he's not in control.
He doesn't want to be there.
He doesn't
want other
people think to think he has to be there.
So he's he's trying to dominate it,
dominate the dynamic simply
by if he thinks being something right now
shows his power. Power. Yes. Right.
So it's not a revealing moment.
It's purposeful, not purposeful.
Okay.
Which I think is obviously significant
that you share that.
So
Did you ever think you'd see a day
like this?
You know,
from the time I was growing up in
Kansas today, I.
I hoped
all my life as an American
that I would never see a day like this.
I think it was a very sad day
for America.
It's
the gravity of it can't be overstated.
So, no, I never thought I'd see a day
like today.
And now here we are talking about
what happens next.
So while.
Well, not at the Trump aide, right.
Who right
by his side
right now on that plane
going to get off
and be by his side in Bedminster,
an alleged coconspirator
with him at the restaurant with him
every step of the way. Right.
No separation between the two.
He's going to be arraigned in two weeks
because he doesn't have
representation yet. Ty,
do you see any reason why not?
Whatever. Whatever.
And I've been asking this ever
why he would ever turn on Trump,
but also given what we know
in the indictment.
Do they need him, too?
So those are two great questions.
And they are as distinct as you put them.
One, do I think
somebody may be able
to convince him that his notwithstanding
how proud he is of his service
to the president
and not how not withstanding
how proud he is of,
you know, his belief
that he's still serving the country
by serving the president, that
that will make it very hard
for him to flip
unless he gets representation
that is able to persuade him
of how misplaced that loyalty is
and how overwhelming the facts are.
I heard one guest
earlier today talk about the
perceived
unlikelihood of not being convicted.
He's dead.
I mean, they have him on tape.
They have him.
They have pictures,
they have text,
they've got video, they've got pictures.
They've got pictures that he took.
And sent,
you know, there's
and then he moved the boxes
and the
you know, as a result,
the attorneys weren't
able to find the documents.
You know, he's
definitely in substantial jeopardy.
And
and I think, Wolf will be convicted
unless he testifies and
on the issue of do they need him?
They need him a lot less now
than they once did.
And particularly, you know,
his initial denials,
which were unfortunate,
you know, that that may contribute
to the government
deciding just to proceed.
You know, not even give him a chance
just to proceed with that, another offer.
So Cy Vance, former D.A.
here in New York, was on earlier.
And we were talking about
the attorney general
in New York, Letitia James.
She is saying that everything else
is going to go on the back burner
because of this case.
She was including Alvin Bragg.
She also was including yet
uncharged crimes in Georgia.
Which she said would take a back burner.
Of course, there's
also the potential of the special counsel
to bring January 6th charges.
I mean, there's a lot of possible
and I coming down the pike.
Do you agree with her analysis?
That this has now become
the single most important thing
and that the system, the judges will that
there will be a sense of either
hold off on indictments
or hold off on cases until this is done.
So I agree with her assessment
without her assessment.
I mean, this is the most important thing
going on Her assessment is telling to me
because I believe, as would be typical,
given the number of prosecutors involved,
that there's some coordination going on
you know, about dates
or about times or about
we want this witness now
and you can have him when.
But the the reality is
I do believe that everything will take
take a backseat to this.
With the exception of January 6th,
which will continue to proceed.
But
I don't think that will proceed quickly
to an indictment.
I think that decision will be delayed
and that they're still on the fence
about an indictment
or a or a full report.
All right.
Thank you very much, Ty Cobb. Pleasure.